el centro histórico de Odessa declarado
patrimonio mundial en peligro este
miércoles la agencia cultural de
Naciones Unidas la UNESCO le dio este
estatus a la portuaria urbe ucraniana
con el fin de proteger su patrimonio
cultural amenazado por los ataques rusos
desde que el kremlin invadiera Ucrania
hace casi un año
hubo primero un aspecto simbólico que es
el de decir esta ciudad pertenece al
patrimonio mundial nos concierne a todos
todos la miramos todos la vemos y
reconocemos su historia y su
contribución al patrimonio
194 estados Son miembros de esta
convención y hay una obligación para
todos los estados miembros de no llevar
a cabo una destrucción deliberada de
este patrimonio a su patrimonio Y es que
solo Rusia votó en contra los habitantes
de Odessa situada a las orillas del mar
Negro celebraron la decisión la ciudad
fundada en los últimos años del siglo
XVIII fue bombardeada en varias
ocasiones por las tropas del kremlin
incluso destruyeron las ventanas del
museo bellas artes
será una garantía adicional de la
preservación de estos lugares durante la
guerra para los residentes ordinarios de
Odessa es una garantía de que los sitios
del patrimonio cultural no serán
privatizados no serán utilizados de una
manera que no deberían ser utilizados
personalmente Espero que nuestra ciudad
conserve el estilo original que teníamos
y que es conocido en todo el mundo la
arquitectura que tenemos se conservará
Odessa también sufrió daños durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial pero su histórica
arquitectura quedó casi intacta su
Encanto arquitectónico la convirtió en
un reclamo turístico la ciudad hace una
hora los otros siete sitios de
patrimonio mundial de Ucrania como la
catedral de Santa Sofía y varios
edificios religiosos en kie